[Music]
a century ago
the apocalyptic abounded and it echoes
in today's political discourse
activist progressives have a history of
apocalypticism on issues like climate
change
but now some on the political right have
been captivated by these very same
impulses
the problem with apocalyptic politics is
two-fold it corrupts public life by
reducing the non-political complexity of
life
to political warfare and secondly it
blinds us to everything that's actually
going well
so what came of the apocalyptism of the
1920s
well in the wake of the great depression
and world war ii imaginative thought
leaders focused on what was good and
true in western civilization
and america experienced the flowering of
literary cultural and economic progress
so what are the good things hiding in
plain sight today from a newfound
awareness of the importance of marriage
and faith
to americans strong sense of place
patriotism and belief in the american
dream
to a robust embrace of education
innovation and medical breakthroughs
it is the recoverists who will find each
other and defend the first principles
practices and institutions on which all
of these good things depend
so how worried are you about america's
future let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei